Brian you and I have dealt in different
ways with the Multiverse I've been much
more on the full philosophical side
you've been on the experimentalist not
very deeply involved but let's take both
of us take a step back and ask what
multiverses would mean in the biggest
sense of the term and we have meaning in
different categories meaning for physics
meaning for cosmology for philosophy
even theology so let's just go through
the list for physics I mean the argument
is that if there's a real Multiverse and
there are different universes created by
different by inflationary Theory or
colliding brains or some other way of
having different uh characterizations of
physical reality that they may have
different physical constants so physics
may be different right that's right yeah
and you'd have different energy levels
for the vacuum which could cause
different properties of those physical
constants and interactions there might
be more forces of nature if you are I
mean don't forget if we had this
conversation 100 years ago we wouldn't
know about you know three of the you
know are the three of the fundamental
forces of nature right so
um that's right so we should never
underestimate our ignorance of what will
come by Future clever experimentalists
right that observations that come from
Serendipity the problem is that all the
low-lying fruit is getting the tree is
Barren until the maybe the very top but
maybe there's nothing up there maybe
there's no high hanging fruit left to
pick
um and so is it dangerous as Paul
steinhard has said the Multiverse is
dangerous not just to science but to
society now Paul's a friend of mine do I
agree with that statement how in what
sense can can it denigrate and I know
what he's saying he's a he's saying it
in the strict paparian sense of the of
the term that science should be
falsifiable and that the Multiverse is
unfalsifiable intrinsically because you
could have a variety of different
physical origin states of the universe
that lead to the observed observation
that we have and therefore there's not a
one-to-one injection of and there's no
way to falsify something that you that
has no characteristics the fault of it
right but if I tell you you a Virgo and
you say oh tomorrow you know you're
going to win the lottery and I don't win
the lottery you falsified it so is
astrology now part of the falsified
scientific method of course not it's
ridiculous yeah so um and I'm not saying
that conjecturing that the Multiverse
can have harm now where does it have
harm uh ultimately I think it has the
most harm in the sociology of science
that's very hard to get uh to work on
alternatives to cosmology I mean you and
I could talk about the five different
alternatives to inflation and remember
inflation is is a misnomer there's
really at least a thousand different
models of information and each one has a
cosmologist standing behind you know his
or her favorite Theory right but there's
literally five maybe five Alternatives
and most of those are considered you
know some of those are considered Fringe
you know by by Alternatives some are
considered um uh no better than
inflation here here's here's here's one
reason that I've had trouble with
alternatives to inflation even though I
think it's exciting and important to
think about them and what should a good
alternative to a model have well let's
just cut away all the nonsense what they
most object to is the Multiverse right
so it shouldn't have a Multiverse so
none of these Alternatives have a
Multiverse at least in the classic sense
of parallel universes right now they do
have multiverses in time temporal right
they have temporal cichlid but let's
ignore that what is the element that
causes inflation at its core to occur
it's called a scalar field it's called
the inflaton you'd like ideally your
Quantum alternative to inflation to have
no scalar field right because that is
the cynical non of inflation well guess
what all these models have have it and
I'm not look almost a simple
experimental as I'm not able to come up
with these models but all the
Alternatives have some unknown
um as yet no better than the inflaton
component whether it's a scalar tracking
field whether it's sir Roger Penrose
aerobonds if I'm a dark matter that
evolves and the decays there's no
evidence for any of those so is it
Improvement it gets rid of the
Multiverse but at what cost and I think
the most intellectually satisfying would
be something that doesn't have an
unknown scalar field or maybe that
scalar field is the Higgs and then okay
we know it and it connects to it but as
yet those attempts at synthesis have
been unsuccessful what are implications
of the of the Multiverse for philosophy
or theology I think there's a lot with
philosophy a fee it's it's been used in
some sense to kind of provide a
mechanism by which the anthropic
principle is instantiated that life is
bound to occur given an infinite number
of constant now some people agree and
argue rather that the Universe Isn't So
finely tuned Fred Adams for example has
argued that the universe is very you
know loose tuned and so you're kind of
using gloves on the radio knob right uh
but uh but in but in reality he's
restricting his attention to a very
narrow subset of what he calls the base
level the cynical non for us to be
asking an anthropic question which is
the formation of stars right so if he's
restricted now what if you layer in
every single physical constant or every
single property that makes life livable
on Earth after all we only know of life
on Earth we don't know a single bit of
evidence for any other statement to the
contrary is a faith-based statement
people say I believe there's like I
don't believe in gravity I know gravity
exists I have evidence for Gravity I
don't have to believe in it so belief is
a faith-based question so theologically
I think there are people so so funny
when the bicep result was announced
March 17 2014 at Harvard Nobel prizes
Galore for everybody but there were
arguments from people on the theological
sense this proves God exists because it
was concomitant with inflation which
looks a lot like a singularity of the
universe and then there were opponents
like Lawrence Krauss uh and and Max
tagmark we said you know goodbye
Universe hello Multiverse so it's maybe
before you don't need God at all because
you you have you know you can explain
the fine-tuning of our universe because
you can explain everything and we're
here with the anthropic principle that's
right so it can either depending on your
lens it can either prove God's existence
or make God utterly irrelevant right and
it shows kind of the interest in it and
the excitement of it and that's why
we're so passionately pursuing it with
instruments like the Simon's Observatory